Britta's decision to leave the EU was
the hot topic for debate again in this
week's plenary session one thing was
clear in politics things can move fast
if Stella North has tossed Easter Island
and blacks eat Alden from Gaston the
whole Egan held in for her to see
leaders of Parliament's main groups have
begun drawing red lines from what comes
next the pin and marked is instant
abundant meeting current fry heightened
he snitched acceptable does the last
wagon private aft is incontinent Abadi
burger for fresh lost nine o'clock women
fifteen banal adición de Illinois
riccati Dean on ferret rata TV prima
Delano TV the levanta diverges so no a
consider are a loony on a rope a menu
that who is ashamed Lapierre danced
against either the leader of Britain's
Conservatives in Parliament had his word
next the British referendum was just the
latest wake-up call for the EU and many
rightly respond by calling for more
reform the more the commissioners
European parliamentarians and national
leaders try to pressure the UK the more
they justify the decision that our
British people have taken from the
Liberals a word of warning to Europe's
leadership this type of European Union
of today you cannot defend it anymore
and that Europe needs to be reformed
because the truth is that European
citizens are not against Europe they are
against this Europe many hope clarity
and definition on that question will
come in a special summit in Slovakia
after the summer break